154 is one standard diviation below the mean. So we're trying to find out what
proportion of people are in this green region. Well, let's start with what we
know. We know that 34% is between one standard devaition below the mean and the
mean. And 34% is between the mean and one standard deviation above the mean. The
mean because that makes 68% here. And we also know that 95% is between two
center deviations below the mean and two above the mean, 95 minus 68 is 27 so
27% is distributed between this area and this area meaning that 13.5% is here.
And 13.5% is here, And you already found that, that leaves 5% to be distributed
between the two tails, below two center deviations below the mean and above two
center deviations above the mean. So we know here, this is 2.5% and this is
2.5%. Now, we pretty much have our answer. 13.5% plus 2.5% is 16%, so that's a
proportion of 0.16.